The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from 100 of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So today then we are going
to talk about eye movement
control.
This is a fact-laden
set of topics.
We're going to talk about
the basics of eye movements,
and then we're going to talk
about the various neural
structures that are involved
in eye movement control.
The interesting thing about
studying eye movement control
here, which is very closely,
obviously related to vision.
It's also very closely related
to the ocular motor system
because it involves
moving the eyes.
Now the basic fact is
that we move our eyes
practically endlessly every day.
We make about three
saccades a second.
And we make more than
150,000 saccades every day.
And it's not something
you ever think about.
Yet every time you
look at something,
you have to decide as to where
you're going to look next.
You're not even aware of it.
It just happens automatically.
It's a remarkable system,
works with incredible rapidity,
and it involves recognizing
objects out there,
recognizing the visual
scenes, making a selection,
moving your eye there,
and you keep doing it,
as I said, three times a second.
So this is, obviously,
the eye movements
that you make like that, jumping
from one location to another.
And with each of those eye
movements, as I've said,
you need to decide where
are you going to look next.
So that's quite an amazing feat.
And it's not just something
that we do as humans,
but it's also done
regularly by animals.
And most of the work
I will tell you about
has been conducted actually on
monkeys whose eye movements are
remarkably similar to
those of our eye movements.
Now let's first of
all go over what
I'm going to cover in
the next two sessions.
First of all, before
I do that, I just
thought I'll show you an
amusing cartoon from The New
Yorker, which was made
in 2001 which sort of
puts in a nutshell what
the nature of all this is.
Here's a cat.
He's going to try to jump
up there to get the thing.
And so it has to make a decision
where that thing is in space,
has to make the
calculations, as to how
to generate the motor
activities to jump up there.
Now when it comes to
the eye movements,
you don't have to
jump up there, but you
have to decide how to
jump your eye from one
location to the next.
So what we are going
to try to understand
is what are these
calculations that we perform
to be able to make accurate
eye movements from one location
to another.
And what neural structures
are involved in this,
and what are the various
rules these neural structures
are involved in to generate
those eye movements.
Now here are the topics.
First of all,
we're going to look
at just the basics
of eye movements.
Then we are going to look
at the so-called eye plant
and the brain stem
nuclei, which are
involved in moving
your eye muscles.
Then, we are going to look at
an important structure in eye
movement generation which is
called the superior colliculus
that we hadn't talked about yet.
And then we are going to
look at the visual input
for saccade generation.
We're going to examine
what the various types
of retinal ganglion cells do
to be involved in eye movement
generation.
In particular, we
are going to look
at the midget and
the parasol cells.
Then perhaps a little bit today,
but most of the next time,
we can look at the
cortical structures
involved in movement control.
Then we're going to look
at the effects of paired
electrical and
visual stimulation
because that would give
us additional insights
about the nature
of eye movements.
And then we're going
to look at what
happens when you have various
deficits in motor control
as a result of having
lesions in various parts
of the visual and
ocular motor systems.
And then we're going to look
at some pharmacological studies
to try to understand what the
pharmacology is of eye movement
control.
And I should only say visually
guided eye movement control.
All right.
So let's first start then with
the basics of eye movements.
We can ask a question,
why do we move our eyes.
Now you already have the
answer to the first reason
we do that, which is
that in the retina,
we have a highly specialized
system in higher mammals
and humans where there's
only a very small area
where you have a very high
density of photoreceptors.
And so to see fine
detail, you need
to move your eye to
the location to be
able to analyze it at
a high level acuity.
So that then involves
the directive
to acquire objects
for central viewing.
Because it's the
central viewing that
allows you to have high acuity.
Now those are
accomplished predominantly
by saccadic eye movements,
just like the ones
I had mimicked at
the very beginning.
You make these very
rapid eye movements
fro one location to another.
Another important part
of eye movement control
is that when either your are
in motion, or whatever you're
looking at, like a
bird flying in the sky,
to be able to analyze it,
you track that object.
You make what is called
smooth pursuit eye movements.
So that is another
important mechanism
that enables you to analyze
things accurately in the world.
Now yet another factor is
that when we move about,
it's important for us
to be able for our eyes
to be stable with respect
to the world out there.
And one of the
mechanisms involved
in that, as we shall see, is
the accessory optic system--
and that's what you're going to
be writing a paper about-- that
is involved in controlling
the eyes involving
both visual stimuli and
the vestibular system.
So that is what we're
going to talk about.
Actually that part
we're probably
going to talk about
when we-- in the next
to last lecture, not next
time, but the time after.
We're going to talk about the
accessory optic system a bit.
All right.
So now then, just
to reiterate then,
we're talking about
the vestibular ocular
reflex and the
accessory optic system.
So now then, people have
classified eye movements
into some very basic types.
We have so-called conjugate
eye movements when the two
eyes move in unison, and
then vergence eye movements
of an object comes close to
you, it goes away from you,
then the two eyes
converge or diverge.
And that still has to
be done to make sure
that the images you
see in the world
fall upon corresponding
regions of the two eyes.
Now the conjugate eye movements
fall into two basic categories.
They're called
saccadic eye movements,
the ones we have talked
about already a bit,
and smooth pursuit
eye movements that
causes us to be
able to track object
so that we can keep that
object on the fovea.
Now vergence eye
movement-- you go back
to that picture I'd shown
you before in which you have
the horopter or the Vieth-Muller
circle, if you remember.
If any object is along
the Vieth-Muller circle,
like going from 1 to 2, say an
object jumps from here to here,
then when the eyes
track it, they
follow in corresponding
points into two retinae.
However, if there is an object
that falls outside or inside
the Vieth-Muller circle, as
shown here, then the object,
the second object follows
an non-corresponding point.
And so therefore you have to
bring about eye movements that
involved vergence-- either
divergence or convergence.
For the most part, we
get, today especially
and the next time
as well, we're going
to be talking about
saccadic eye movements.
And then as I said, after
we have covered movement,
we're going to look
at the movements that
involve pursuit and vergence.
Let's now take a look
at a human subject
and see the eye movements
the subject makes.
I mean, you're
perfectly aware of it,
but I thought it would be
fun for you to look at it.
So here's a subject, and he's
looking at something, right?
And all these eye
movements obvious there's
nothing moving out
there, so these are all
saccadic eye movements.
The head is fixed.
And so now once
you've seen this,
there are a number of questions
that comes into one's mind.
The first one, on the
not too scientific end,
is well was that
a male or female.
Or secondly, what was
a person looking at?
And then thirdly, way down
the list you say, but how does
the brain do this.
So let's see if you can
answer these three questions.
The third one will
take the two lectures.
But the first and second one
can be answers fairly quickly.
Was it a male or female?
Anybody want commit themselves?
AUDIENCE: Male, male, male.
PROFESSOR: Male, male, male.
Anybody think it was a female?
You guys are good.
It was a male.
Very good.
All right.
Now the second
thing, of course, is
what on earth was this
person looking at.
Now there's no way you could
glean that until I tell you.
So let me tell you what
this person is looking at.
And what this person
looking at is up
picture which is created
by Rene Magritte.
And actually resides in at
the National Gallery of Art
in Washington DC.
That's quite an
interesting painting,
and that's what I'm
showing it to you.
And it relates closely
to perception--
the curious aspects of it.
And you can see this doesn't
make sense quite right.
But it's because
of that, because
of the puzzling nature
of this picture that it
is in the fabulous museum.
Because it is so unusual
and different that it makes
you think.
So anyway, what happens then
suppose you started here
when picture came
on, then you're
going to have to
make a decision where
you're going to look next.
So what would you look at next?
Most, commonly, would look
at the eyes Of the rider.
Then you would look at
the eyes of the horse.
And so I look at various
outstanding features.
Now the way this looks, more or
less-- looks like in real time,
looks like this.
So that's what this
person was looking at.
And that makes you
aware of the fact
that whenever you look at the
pictures, you look at anything,
you make all these eye movements
in this very short time for you
to comprehend the scene and to
understand it in some detail.
When this kind of eye
movement series is made,
you wonder is this something
that animals also do.
And the answer is yes.
Monkeys certainly do.
Most mammals do, and even
birds do this kind of stuff.
So what I want to
show you next is,
first of all, what the
pattern of eye movements
is in humans and the
initial person who
did beautiful work on
this who's name is Yarbus.
Now this is a famous sculpture.
This sculpture the
so-called Bust of Nefertiti.
And what Yarbus did is he looked
at the kinds of eye movements
a person makes when
they look at this figure
to be to comprehend it.
And you can see
what is interesting
about this is there is a lot
of saccades along the edges,
and there's a lot of detail,
and not too many saccades
made to regions where
there's smooth areas.
So what Yarbus did, he
actually published a book
on this analyzing the
nature of our eye movements
just looking at its
behavior like this.
Now if you do the same
thing with monkeys,
they are going to show you that
monkey, a bunch of monkeys,
they also move their
eyes just like we do.
They also have foveas, of
course, as we discussed.
And so as they move around
and look around in the world,
they make even more eye
movements than we do.
They're a little bit
more quick about it,
and so they make many,
many eye movements
and make about maybe almost
four saccades a second.
Now to see whether they
also actually select objects
in a sensible way,
what you can do
is you can present
a bunch of displays.
Here is a bunch of round
ones-- in round locations,
I should say--
different objects.
And here we have a
bunch of them arranged
in a rectangular fashion.
Then on the right, with the
[INAUDIBLE] fixed again,
you see the kinds of eye
movements the monkey makes.
And what you can readily do,
even if you didn't see these
here, you can tell
that there must
be a whole bunch of
objects at these locations,
including one in the
center, and here,
that the objects must be-- are
aligned the way they are there.
So clearly the monkeys
do the same thing we do.
They tend to look at particular
objects in the scene,
and make accurate
saccades to them
to be able to analyze them.
So because of that, it is
natural to take monkeys
and to study their eye
movements and to study
the underlying neural mechanisms
in these animals, which
would then make us more
capable of understanding
just how the brain
moves your eyes about.
So now, let us becoming more
concerned with the neural
mechanisms and the machinery
involved in eye movement
generation.
And so we are going to
refer to this as eye plant
and the brain stem
nuclei, which are
in the mid and lower portions
of the brain, not in the cortex.
We'll talk about the
cortical factors later on.
So let's start first of
all, with the muscles.
Each eye have six
extraocular muscles,
as they are delineated here.
They're called the superior
and inferior recti,
the medial and lateral
recti, and the obliques,
the superior and
inferior oblique muscles.
Now the remarkable feature
about these muscles
that renders them
different from the muscles
that you have in the
rest of your body
is that the fibers
of each muscle
run the entire length
of the muscle itself.
It's not segmented.
Most muscles in the
body are segmented.
Because of that, they're
often difficult to understand
the nature of the operation.
But here we have a situation
that since all the fibers
on the entire length,
it is a relatively easy
to comprehend the basic
mechanisms that generate
the eye movements
at this low level.
The next thing that's
important to know
is that the eye is a
balanced structure.
It doesn't have any
weights anywhere.
And so when you
move the eyes, it's
not like when you have
to pick up an object.
If you were to pick
up a heavy object
and you thought it
was a feather then
you would practically
hit yourself in the face.
But if you know what the object
is, you can correct for the way
you're going to
lift it, which adds
another huge dimension on
how you move your body about,
and how you operate
your muscles.
Luckily when it comes to the
eyes, that is not a factor.
And because of that,
it's easier to understand
the way it operates.
So now that you have this,
the next question one can ask
is how are these
muscles innervated.
I mean obviously, you have
to have some nerves that
connect to it that's cause
the muscles to contract
or to let go.
The way that works is
that the nerves that
connect to the muscles
of the eye release
acetylcholine that causes
the muscle to contract.
OK so that's a basic-- that
happens everywhere in the body.
So that's very basic.
You already know all that.
But what you probably
don't know yet
is what are the nuerons--
where do they come from,
in other words, to
innervate these muscles.
Well it turns out that there
are three cranial nerves--
how many cranial nerves
are there in the brain?
AUDIENCE: 12.
12?
PROFESSOR: 12.
3 of those, believe
it or not, are
involved in the control
of eye movement.
And so we can designate that.
We can tell you that
the lateral rectus
is innervated by
the abducens nerve.
The abducens nerve comes
from the abducens nucleus.
The superior oblique
muscle is innervated
by trochlear nerve, which
is the fourth cranial nerve.
And the rest of
them are innervated
by sub-nuclei of the
third nerve, which
is called the oculomotor nerve.
So we have these three
oculomotor is a third,
trochlear is the fourth,
and abducens is the sixth.
So it's these three
nuclei which-- note again
that the oculomotor
has sub-nuclei--
that innervate these muscles.
So now that we know
that, the next question
is how do these neurons
from these three nuclei
act to do this.
But before I tell
you that, I want
to make sure that you learn
what the 12 cranial nuclei are.
What you can do
here-- and I'm using
a so-called clean
mnemonic device.
On old Olympus towering
tops a fat armed girl vends
snowy hops.
That's easy enough to remember.
The first letter
of each designates
each of the 12 cranial nerves.
So if we then look at
that, here they are.
The first one is the olfactory
one, the second is the optic.
Then we have the
ones in blue here,
which innervate
the eye muscles--
oculomotor, trochlear, abducens.
And then one important
ones that you're
going to hear a lot about
is the auditory one--
that's number eight.
So those are 12 cranial nerves.
And then, you don't
have to remember this,
it might help to
know that, of course,
you have a whole bunch
of spinal nerves as well.
You have 31 of them.
And those 31, of course,
each doubles-- one
on the left side, one
on the right side.
You have 8 cervical, 12
thoracic, 5 lumbar, 5 sacral,
and 1 coccygeal.
Now you don't-- as I say, you
don't have to remember this.
And I'm not even tell you
have to remember these.
But it's good to know that.
It's something that you
can commit to memory,
so that when you go to a
party and talk to somebody,
you can say, hey, you know
about the 12 cranial nerves.
And they go, [YAWNS],
see you later.
All right.
So anyway, we can
move on now and see
how these neurons that
innervate the muscles, that
are so often referred to as
a final common path-- how
they operate.
Actually that underwent
quite a bit of debate
for a long, long time.
We're not going to go
into the debate itself,
but I'm just going to
tell you how it works.
But the fact is
that these neurons
are involved in generating
all sorts of eye-- all the eye
movements we talk about,
meaning smooth pursuit,
meaning maintained eye
position, and saccade.
And so here's an example.
This show vertical
eye movements, just
vertical eye movements.
And what you can see here
is that the more they eye
looks down, like here, the
more sustained activity
to keep the muscle contracted,
to keep the eye down.
Now but you also have to
remember that while this
is happening here,
the opposite muscle
on top, the superior
rectus, has to let go.
So there would be no
activity to contract
the muscle in the superior
rectus-- no muscle
fibers in the superior rectus.
Secondly, the important
thing to notice here
is that whenever
there's a saccade--
saccade, saccade,
and so on, when there's
a little saccade,
there's a high frequency burst.
And the high frequency is short.
When you have a big
saccade, there's
a much longer high
frequency burst.
And when there's a saccade
in the opposite direction,
there is a pause.
So what do you think happens
when there's a pause?
In that case, the superior
rectus would get a burst
and would contract rapidly to
get an upward eye movement.
So this muscle will cause
your downward eye movement,
and the superior rectus records
an upward movement, of course.
So that is the basic layout.
Now this is schematic, but to
show you that this is real,
I'm going to show you some
data here of a monkey doing
the actual eye movements,
recording from the ocular motor
nucleus.
And in this case again,
invading the inferior rectus.
And what you can see here
are a bunch of saccades.
And here the monkey is tracking
an apple as it moved down.
And what you can
see-- let's look first
at this at the bottom.
What you can see here is
that somewhere along the line
here is what the
monkey's tracking.
This particular neuron
begins to cut in,
and then gradually
it increases the rate
of its activity as
a result of which,
you get smooth
pursuit eye movements.
Now if you look
at the upper part,
once again as I've shown you,
the frequency of activity
is proportional to the angular
deviation of the eye, this case
because you're talking
about the inferior rectus,
in the vertical dimension.
And whenever there's
a saccade downward,
there's a high frequency burst.
And whenever there's a saccade
upward, there's a pause.
So that is the basic
nature of this.
And what is so lovely about
this, is it's like a machine.
This is so lovely
that if you then
collect data from several cells,
and here's an example of it,
and you look at the number
of spikes per second
and the angular
deviation of the eye,
it shows you that each
of these four neurons
acts in a linear fashion.
As the eye deviates
more and more,
the frequency, the activity,
gradually increases.
This is not saccades, obviously.
This is maintained activity--
let me go back again--
like here, like here,
like here, and like here.
So you get this beautiful linear
function, which again as I've
said, makes it relatively easy
to understand quantitatively
the process of moving the eyes.
So that is the basic
mechanism that you
see in the oculomotor nuclei.
And the important thing
to understand then
is that the activity
of these neurons
is involved both in
the making saccades
and in maintaining
various eye positions.
The reason I emphasize
this is because maybe
about 30 years ago,
there was a big debate.
Some people argued,
and they initially
began to record from
these oculomotor nuclei
that we have two
different sets of neurons
in the final common path, one
of which controls saccades,
and one of which controls
maintained position,
or smooth pursuit.
But that's not the case.
The case is that
these neurons do both.
Now why did this
confusion arise?
Well, it arose
because it was found
that if you looked at the
so-called supranuclear
complex, which are neurons which
are sort of above, if you will,
the oculomotor, trochlear,
and abducens nuclei,
there are a whole bunch
of subnuclei there--
we're not going to go
into details about them.
You don't have to know that.
But at any rate, in
those nuclei there
are neurons that are
indeed separately coding
different attributes.
I'm going to show
this, but before I
do I want to make one
more important point.
If you take a microelectrode,
and you put it
in one of these nuclei that
controls a final common path,
if you stimulate there at a
high frequency, in this case
500 Hertz, if you increase the
duration of the stimulation,
you get progressively
bigger saccades,
Which proves, with
stimulation that it's indeed
the duration of the high
frequency burst that defines
the size of the saccade
that you elicit.
So now we can move on.
And in this case as I say,
you don't have to know this,
but I want to just
mention it briefly.
We have a [INAUDIBLE]
the eye-- the eye muscle.
And then we have, in addition
to the final common path,
we have a supranuclear complex,
which have various neuron, some
which pause, in other words,
that don't cause saccades,
and some which fire
only to saccades.
I think that's the only
ones I need to point out.
But at that level,
they're separate.
But once they come together
in the oculomotor complex,
then they impinge
on these neurons
of the final common path that
carry both of these signals.
So that then is the essence
of the oculomotor complex
that I want to cover.
And so we can a quick,
summary diagram here.
We're going to make
a diagram that's
going to grow over in this
session and the next one,
and that's going to be
very complex in the end,
unfortunately.
But here we have the brain
stem oculomotor complex.
And the way to put
this-- because you
talk about what kinds of coding
operations are involved-- this
carries what you're going
to call a rate code.
The higher the rate, the
greater the angular deviation
of the eye.
And of course, the longer
the high frequency burst,
the bigger the saccade.
So that is the
so-called rate code.
So this is the
basic layout then.
And of course, if there's
a lot of activity here,
this muscle is
going to contract,
the eye is going to
deviate downward.
At the same time, you're
going to get a signal
to the upper part
that's going to let go.
In other words,
the signal is going
to be terminated
so that you have
no activity in the upper part,
so that that muscle can expand.
So that's basically
it at this point.
And as I say, this will grow,
and grow, and grow, and grow,
until by the end
of next time, it's
going to be really complicated.
But that's how the brain works.
It's complicated.
So with that then,
we are next going
to move to the so-called
superior colliculus.
Now the first thing I want
to say about this structure
is that this region of
the brain-- I'll show you
a picture of it
in just a minute--
is one that has undergone
tremendous changes
in the course of evolution.
In more primitive
animals, like in fish
and in amphibia,
what you find is
that this structure is the prime
structure for analyzing vision.
So it does vision
and then generates
commands of various
sorts, including
commands to make eye
movements, or generate
other kinds of movements
in different animals.
And this is the case
because in these animals,
there is very little cortex.
But with the process
of encephalization
more and more of the
analytical undertakings
the brain was involved in had
been relegated to the cortex.
And that also meant
that more and more
of the way we analyze
vision became more central,
as we have discussed already,
with cortical mechanisms.
Now to make this
clear, let me show
you three drawings of a
so-called toad, a rabbit,
and a monkey.
And what you see
here, the toad--
here is the superior colliculus.
This structure is
quite large relative
to the rest of the brain.
Then when you come
to the rabbit,
there's some degree
of encephalization.
So this structure
is much smaller
relative to the
rest of the brain.
And then when it
comes to the monkey,
it looks like the superior
colliculus is actually
quite tiny.
And in monkeys and humans,
the superior colliculus
is very small.
It's maybe about five or
six millimeters in diameter.
And yet, it's an extremely
important structure
and we're going to examine
just what the structure does.
And later on, we're
going to examine
what happens if you
lose that structure.
So now here is a sagittal
midline section of the monkey.
So you can see this real.
And here we have
the lunate again.
This is what part
of the brain here?
This is a cephalic area.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, good.
This is area V1 here.
Then if you look down here,
you see this little bubble
looking thing here?
That's the superior colliculus.
So that is a
structure that we are
going to look at in some detail.
Now if one enlarges this--
this in a cat actually--
and one takes a
coronal cross section
of the superior
colliculus, they can
see it's a fairly
complicated structure.
It has several layers.
People have distinguished
at least seven clear layers.
And you can see
the upper part here
is often referred to
as superficial gray.
There are two layers of that.
The very top layer gets an
input directly from the retina.
The one little
further down, I'll
elaborate on that in the minute.
It gets input from
the visual cortex.
And then we have a whole
bunch of other layers
that we are going to examine in
some detail in just a minute.
So that's the nature
of the structure--
the superior colliculus.
And the fact is that in more
primitive animals, actually,
it is a structure
with many more layers.
Some of these more
primitive animals
have as many as 14
layers in this structure
because it is heavily involved
in eye movement control,
as well as in the
analysis of vision.
Now the interesting
fact about the way
this is laid out in the
cat, and in higher animals,
and in humans, that most of
the cells in the various layers
reside in those layers.
They don't talk to
each other that much.
But they get a lot of input
from many other structures
that control those layers.
And I'll go into that in
some detail in a minute.
Now the next important fact
about the superior colliculus,
which makes it similar to
lateral geniculate nucleus
in the cortex, is that the
visual field is laid out
in a topographic manner in
the superior colliculus.
This is a top view
of the colliculus.
This is the visual field.
And once again, the
rule, if you remember,
is that the contralateral
half of the visual field
is it projects to the
superior colliculus.
And of course, the opposite then
is the case for the other side.
And then if you look at the
nature of the connections,
you find that everything
that's close to the fovea,
the foveal representation,
projects to the anterior
level of the
superior colliculus.
So this is sort of
the foveal region.
Then the upper
visual field projects
to the medial portion
of the colliculus.
The horizontal
meridian area projects
to the horizontal meridian of
the colliculus in the back.
And the lower part
of the visual field
projects to the lateral
portion of the colliculus.
Now why do I emphasize this?
You will see in just a
minute why that is important.
It's very important
for us understand
that there's a lovely
topographic layout
of the visual field on to
the superior colliculus.
So now we are going
to move on and examine
the question of what is
the nature of the responses
of neurons in the
superior colliculus.
Now I can tell you right off
that in the monkey colliculus,
in the cat
colliculus, the nature
of the responses
of these neurons
is not particularly interesting.
They're small receptive
fields, and they
tend to respond
both to the onset
and the termination
of a visual stimulus,
meaning that they seem to get
an input from both on and off.
And then if you make the a
stimulus progressively larger.
You get an increase
in responses,
but then once you make it quite
large, in this case 10 degrees
and 20 degrees, the
response greatly
declines, which says that
just like in the retina,
these neurons have
centers around antagonism.
And they respond
vigorously to small spots
and very little to large spots.
Now that's a basic layout.
But then if you
ask the question,
well, are these cells in
the colliculus orientation
and direction specific?
Are these cells color selective?
For the most part,
that answer is
no, not entirely, but
mostly no, meaning
that these cells are not
that really interesting.
They are very, very, very basic.
So that is the nature
of the responses
of these neurons in
the superior colliculus
in the superficial layers.
I've told you that the
superficial gray, which
consists of two layers,
the one that that's
a direct input from the
retina, and the other that
gets an input from
the cortex, gives you
vigorous visual responses.
But now, when you
get into the deeper
layers of the colliculus, you
find something very exciting
an extremely interesting.
And that is sort
of diagrammed here.
What you have is a
bunch of eye movements.
And then look at this cell.
This cell responds-- it's the
same cell throughout-- responds
vigorously to a small saccade.
And this responds well
before the saccade is made.
That's what happens here.
But then if the monkey
makes bigger saccades,
and some even in the same
direction, like these here,
you don't get a response.
So what does that mean?
That's curious.
So what that means is that
these cells, some have something
to do with eye movements.
This fires vigorously, and
then eye movement ensues--
fires vigorously and
eye movement ensues.
Now there's an eye movement
that ensues here as well,
but there's no saccade.
So how do we explain this?
Well, what you're do in
these kinds of experiments
then is that you collect
extensive data to see when
a cell like this fires,
and when it doesn't fire.
And you can generate a
response curve, if you will,
or a response diagram
to see when it fires
and when it doesn't fire.
So now to look at that,
here's an example of that.
In this case, all
the white spots
are saccadic eye
movements generated
from a central point that were
not preceded by eye move--
saccadic-- by neural responses.
And the red ones
show the times when
the neurons you're recording
from, the single cell,
responded vigorously.
So that meant that
whatever mark you
made a saccade in
this direction,
there was vigorous
activity in this neuron,
meaning the neuron had an
important role in generating
an eye movement, whereas all
the other saccades did not
generate a responds in
this particular neuron.
But to make this clear, there
are many different neurons
in many different parts
of the colliculus.
And so when you generated
other eye movements,
other neurons fired.
So how can we analyze
this in more detail?
Well, the way we can-- let me
just add one more point here.
This green circle
here is what we're
going to call the motor field
of this particular neuron.
So that's a new concept
for you-- motor field.
These neurons in the
intermediate and deep layers
of the colliculus
have motor field
that define the
size of the saccade.
Now let me say one more
thing in anticipation--
that if you then study where the
cells' visual receptive field
is, it's right there relative
to the central fixation point.
So it means that
this particular cell
fires when a saccade is
made into the receptive
field of that neuron.
So how can we verify this
interesting, clever arrangement
in the superior colliculus?
Well, the way we can do this
is to instead of recording,
or actually I shouldn't
say instead, really.
But we can do two things.
We can record and
see what happens
in different parts
of the colliculus.
Or we can electrically
stimulate there.
Well, so here is a schematic.
Here is a colliculus-- this is
anterior, this is posterior.
So this, obviously,
if you remember,
this is close to the fovea.
And here is medial
and here is lateral.
And what we can do
then, we can see
where the receptive fields
are of these neurons.
And we can plot them out.
Here are the receptive fields.
Here is number 1,
close to the fovea,
number 2 is medial is
up, and lateral is down.
Now that one has done
this, you can switch over
and you can
electrically stimulate.
And look what happens.
If you electrically
stimulate at 1,
you get a saccade that moves
the eye into the receptive
field of that neuron-- that
set of neurons, I should say.
Then if you stimulate in 2, you
get saccades that move it to 2.
And when you simulate in
3, it moves to location 3.
Now what more do we need to
verify given this situation?
How can one believe this
hypothesis, if you will,
at this stage?
What did I tell you about
when you electrically
stimulate the neurons in
the final common paths,
back in abducens, in
the oculomotor nucleus,
for example?
What did I tell you?
That this duration
of the simulation
define the size of the
saccade elicited, right?
Now if that's the case,
if that's were the case,
then this would not mean
a damn thing, would it?
Because you could take that same
location and stimulated longer,
and you would get
a bigger saccade.
So what you need to do?
You need to systematically
vary the duration
of the high frequency
burst in the colliculus
to compare it with what
happens when you stimulate
in the abducens or
oculomotor nuclei.
OK so let's look at that.
Here is a picture
I've shown you before.
As we increase the duration
of the high frequency burst,
you get progressively
biggest saccades.
So now we do the same
thing in the colliculus.
And lo and behold, you get
something totally different
because you have a
totally different code
in the colliculus.
What you get here
is that you get
after you exceed a very
short time-- just 10
milliseconds-- when you
don't get a saccade.
From 25 to about 120
milliseconds, you get saccades,
but they're all
the same size, so
meaning it's where you stimulate
in the colliculus, not how
long you stimulate.
And then to prove
this even further,
when you make the stimulation
much longer than that, you get
a staircase of saccades,
each reaches the same size.
Now yet another proof here
is that if you stimulate
an anterior tip
of the colliculus,
remember where the
receptive fields are very
close to the foveola, then
they get a hold array of,
I think there's something like
14 saccadic eye movements--
bang, bang, bang bang, bang,
bang-- because the simulation
goes on for a long time.
So each little saccade
is the same size,
you just get a
staircase of them.
So that proves that the coding
operation in the colliculus
is one that defines the
location of a receptive field,
and when you stimulate
it, it generates a saccade
that moves the eye into
that receptive field.
So that then in a
nutshell tells you
what the basic principle
is off the functioning
of the colliculus when
it comes to eye movement.
Namely it says, a
saccade is generated
by computing the
size and direction
of the saccadic
vector needed to null
the retinal error between
the present and intended eye
positions.
That's just putting it in a
slightly different way, saying
that, OK, I decide I'm going to
make a saccade to here-- bang,
like that.
Just a saccade line.
And but you did that you
had an intended location.
And by making an eye
movement, you know the error.
Now the colliculus is
really quite accurate.
You can make saccades
with very small error.
Usually the error is
roughly, at most around 10%,
meaning that when you
make very small saccades,
is almost negligible.
When you make a large saccade,
then maybe there is an error.
And when that happens,
sometimes what you have to do
is to make what is called
the corrective saccade.
So suppose you're looking here
and an object appears here.
And so you say, I
intend to go here,
and the colliculus fires in
that region of the colliculus
to generate an eye movement.
And say the eye
movement goes to here.
Then what you have to do is
to make a second saccade,
like that, to correct
for that little error.
So sometimes when you
make large eye movements,
indeed, you make a secondary
saccade for the correction
because your accuracy is
roughly around 90% correct.
Does everybody so far
follow the basic principle?
It's very important to
understand the basic principle
of the operational
characteristics
of the superior colliculus.
So again to repeat, a
saccade is generated
by computing the
size and direction
of the saccadic
vector needed to know
the retinal error between
the present and intended eye
position.
And what you have
in the colliculus
is a cell that is
being activated
because a target falls into it.
And that activation
then generates a signal
to the lower parts
of the colliculus--
we'll talk about that, how that
is done-- which then results
in a saccadic eye movement
that nulls that error signal.
Very clever, very
basic, very beautiful--
and almost computer-like
at this level.
So what we can do now, we are
adding the superior colliculus,
the very basics of it
so far, to this diagram.
And that says that
the colliculus then
sends a signal to
the brain stem.
Some of it initially to
the supranuclear complex,
and then from there
it sends a signal
to the abducens, or
oculomotor, or trochlear nuclei
to generate the
appropriate eye movements.
So that then is
the very basics of
the operational characteristics
of the superior colliculus.
Now what we're
going to do next is
we are going to examine what
the nature of the visual input
is, predominantly the
superior colliculus--
not entirely, but heavily--
to generate a saccadic eye
movement.
So if you remember, I told
you that in the retina,
we make a major distinction
between two classes
of retinal ganglion cells--
the midget and the parasol.
The midget project to
the parvocellular layers
of the colliculus.
And the parasol cells project
to the magnocellular layers.
However, it's also been
found that-- I mentioned
that only briefly,
that in the retina
there is yet another
class of cells
it is called-- some
people have called
it the W cells in the cat.
Other people have called it
the corneal cellular cells that
reside in the relatively
small numbers compared
to the other two throughout the
retina, and project, in part,
to interlaminar layers of the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
But it's been found that
they also project heavily
to the superior colliculus.
Now how do we know this?
Well let me tell
you, it's important
always is to understand the
experimental procedures.
So let me skip that here.
Just to remind you again
are the connections.
This I've shown you
several times before.
So it says here the
interlaminar layers project
to the upper portions
of the visual cortex.
But I didn't tell
you before that
these corneal
cellular cells also
project to the
superior colliculus.
So here's the
And here, initially, we
can ask the question,
what projects look
to the colliculus.
So how do we find out?
Suppose you are in a laboratory
where the big question is what
kinds of cells project
from the retina
to the superior colliculus.
Think about this for a minute.
What kind of experiment
would you do?
How would you find out?
Well, that's quite an
interesting question.
And so to understand
that, I'm going
to tell you about a
couple of techniques.
One technique would be
that you could inject--
anatomical technique--
you would inject
a substance in the colliculus
that would be then retrogradely
transported to the retina, and
would light up the cells there.
That's would be one approach.
Another approach is
that you could actually
record from the retina
itself with microelectrodes.
And you could electrically
stimulate the colliculus.
That way we would be
backdriving cells.
And when you find the
cell in the retina that
is backdriven from
the colliculus,
you know that particular cell
does project to the colliculus.
So that's a very
strong technique
because that enables you then
to identify the cell type
and also you could, if you
do intercellular recording,
to label it.
So they can do the
same thing also--
because I'm going to talk
about that as well-- is
to see what happens
in terms of inputs
to the colliculus
from the cortex.
So let's talk about
each of those,
and that'll give us a
better sense of what
the projections
are from the retina
and from the cortex
to the colliculus.
So here's an example
of how you do it again.
So we are recording
from the retina here,
or in a different experiment,
you can record from the cortex.
You can then electrically
stimulate here.
You can backdrive the
cells in the retina,
or we can backdrive the
cells in the visual cortex.
And then once we do so, and
record it from a single cell,
you can study to
see what it is like.
So that is the approach.
And if you do that, you come
up with some very nice answers.
First of all, these
cells are W-like,
which means that they're like
the corneal cellular cells
that we have seen the retina.
These are these small
cells that are not
particularly rapidly
conducting, obviously
and are not color selective.
And then if we look
at the cells up here,
we find that all those
cells are complex cells,
and they all reside
in layer five.
That's already
known anatomically
that the cells in
layer five are the ones
that project-- many
of them project
to the superior colliculus.
So that then is the
basic procedure.
So now we can expand on
this basic procedure.
What we can do here
is we can record
from the superior colliculus.
And then we can eliminate
the inputs from the cortex
by cooling it.
That's one approach.
So if you do that, you
record from a cell here,
you drive it by
electric stimulation--
by visual stimulation.
We identify that cell
in V1 by backdriving it.
And then once you cool it,
cool the visual cortex,
you see what happens to that
cell in the various layers
of the superior colliculus.
Well when you do that, you get
a very dramatic and, luckily,
clear cut result.
The result is the following.
If you look at the superficial
layers of the colliculus,
and look at what happens
before you cool, when you cool,
and after you cool,
the cells keep firing.
So in these upper layers
in superficial gray,
those cells keep firing.
They're not
interested in anything
that comes down from the cortex.
That's because the
inputs from the retina
goes to these upper layers
of the superior colliculus,
and goes predominantly
to the superficial gray.
However, once you get down
to the intermediate layers,
and the lower layers
as well, every time
you cool, the cell stops
firing, as you can see here.
Which means that these cells
in the intermediate and lower
layers of the
colliculus are driven
by the cortical down flow.
They're not driven by the
direct input from the retina.
So now that we have seen this,
one can say, OK, that's fine.
But is this really something
that happens over time,
or is this just
something peculiar
to the particular
experiment that's been run?
So what do you do to
see if this is really
something-- a permanent effect?
Well, what you can do here
is you can take a monkey,
and you can remove the
visual cortex on one side,
so the monkey can see fine
in half the visual field.
And then you can
record on either side--
the intact side or
the affected side--
in the superior colliculus.
Everybody follow that?
All right.
So if you do that, what you
find is this is the intact side,
and this is the side
where there's no V1.
And this was taken months
after the area V1 was removed.
And here you see these red spots
here, and the red spots here?
That spot is the location
after which you no longer
could drive any cells visually.
So in the intact
side, you can drive it
to very deep layers
of the colliculus.
They had responded very
well to visual stimuli.
But on this side, they
stopped responding here.
So none of these
deeper layers could
be activated by visual stimuli
because those deep layer,
indeed, are driven
by visual inputs
from the downflow
from the cortex.
So that then is the
basic rule of what
has happened in the
superior colliculus.
All right.
Now let's see-- the next
big question we can ask
is this downflow
from the cortex that
drives these important
intermediate layers, which
are involved in eye movement
generation, to what degree are
those cortical
tactile cells driven
by either the parvocellular
or the magnocellular
layer of cells, meaning
by the midget cells,
or the parasol cells.
Well how do you do that?
I've already told
you about experiments
in which what you can do
is you can put a recording
electrode, in this
case in the colliculus.
And then you can inactivate
either the parvocellular
or the magnocellular of the
lateral geniculate nucleus,
while you record in the
superior colliculus.
So what happens is that these
cells then, obviously as shown
here, project to V1, and then
layer five cells project down.
So what we are going
to identify then
is what is the nature of
these cells in layer five
that drive down there.
So first of all,
what this shows is
that if you record
from-- in this case,
from two cells in the
geniculate shown-- sorry,
two cells in the
colliculus shown,
this is under normal
conditions, and this
is when the parvocell
layers are blocked.
Here's another cell--
normal condition,
and then magnocellular
layers are blocked.
So this clearly shows-- and
this was done with dozens,
and dozens, and
dozens of cells--
that blocking the
parvocellular layers,
meaning blocking
the midget system,
had no effect on the cortical
tactile driving of cells,
whereas magnocellular
block eliminated it.
So that meant that these
cells in layer five that
project to the
superior colliculus
are driven exclusively
by the parasol system.
And indeed then,
that was also done--
now let me go back to
that-- that was also done
in another set of
experiments showing that
those cells in the
cortex in layer five,
that you could drive from the
geniculate by backdriving it
if you then block the
midget or parasol cells,
those cells would stop firing.
So those were indeed cells
that were driven exclusively
by the parasol system.
So the parasol system
plays a very important role
in getting-- in
driving the colliculus.
But doing it so only through
the cortex, not directly.
so to then put this in an
easy to remember the diagram,
is to say that when you come to
these high level animals, what
happened is that due
to encephalization,
the cortex gained control
over the superior colliculus,
except the superficial gray.
Everything else
in the colliculus
is controlled by the
cortical downflow.
And that, of course,
became very important
because when you make a
decision as to where you're
going to look next, where you're
going to identify an object,
you have to have information
from the cortex itself,
which then has to be
transferred, in this case,
to the colliculus to generate
the desired eye movement,
so that you can
analyze in detail
what you want to analyze.
So that then is
the basic layout.
And so now what we can
do is we can expand
some more on this diagram,
namely-- once again,
let's go through all this.
We have the brain stem
here, which is a rate code.
And then we have a
superior colliculus.
And that code that we're
going talk about there,
that I've already
described, you can
refer to that as
the vector code.
And then what we
can see here-- some
of this work I've
shown you before--
is that we have these three
systems from the retina
that we talked about now.
The midget, the parasol,
and the W system,
or the corneal cellular system,
that goes up the cortex.
And then the downflow
from V1, we now know,
is driven exclusively, it
seems, by the parasol system.
However, remember also that
when we go to higher cortical
areas-- V2, MT, and V4, and so
on-- these areas, some of them
get a mixed input
from two systems,
like V4 and the temporal lobe.
And MT, on the other
hand, is dominated
by inputs from the parasol
system, but it's not exclusive.
So in the end, the
colliculus also
gets an input from
the midget system.
But the heaviest input to it is
indeed from the parasol system.
So that then is what the diagram
looks like at this point.
And so what we are
going to do next time,
we're going to expand on
this connection in which we
are going to look at
some other cortical
structures-- namely I've already
referred to that a few times--
the frontal eye fields
and the medial eye fields,
which are regions in the cortex
that control eye movements.
And that's what we're going to
look at in much more detail.
So now I'm ready to summarize
what I told you so far.
First of all, there are several
classes of eye movements
one can distinguish.
Those are vergence eye movements
and conjugate eye movements.
And the conjugate
eye movements come
in two major types, which
we call the smooth pursuit
type and the saccadic type.
Then we're going to
talk about eye movements
as a result of the 6 extraocular
muscles that we have.
And important to note that
these extraocular muscles are
such that the
fibers in the muscle
run the entire length
of the muscles.
They're not segmented,
and that they
are innervated by the
third, fourth, and sixth
cranial nerves.
Then we say that
the discharge rate
in neurons of the
final common path
is proportional to the
angular deviation of the eye.
Saccade size is a
function of the duration
of the high frequency
burst in these neurons.
And if you look it up
and down eye movements,
as I've shown you, if the
more the muscles contract that
are the inferior recti, the more
the idea deviates downwards.
And because it's reciprocal, as
the eye deviates more and more,
the superior rectus is
activated less and less.
So we have this
proportional arrangements.
It's as beautiful as I've shown
you-- a linear system that
defines very accurately
the degree of deviation
of the eye as a function
of the frequency
of the neuronal activity.
Then the superior colliculus
codes saccadic vectors
whose amplitude and direction is
laid out in an orderly fashion
and is in register with the
visual receptive fields.
I told you that in the
anterior colliculus,
the receptive fields are
very close to the fovea.
And then you go to the
back of the colliculus,
the progressively further
peripheral, and medial is up,
lateral is down.
It's a nice orderly arrangement.
And you have an arrangement
where the visual receptive
fields and the motor fields are
in register with each other.
And every time there's activity,
there's a particular receptive
field location, the
result is that a saccade
will move the eye into the
receptive field, thereby
nulling the retinal
error signal.
And then the retinal input
to the superior colliculus
comes predominantly
from w-like cells.
But the cortical downflow from
V1, which comes from layer 5,
is driven by the parasol system.
But we should not
neglect the fact--
I'm not sure if you're-- neglect
the fact that they are other
pathways to which the midget
system can also make maybe
a more limited contribution
in generating eye movements.
And as a diagram
I had shown you,
I demonstrated that
the superior colliculus
is on the cortical control
in higher primates.
So that then is the essence of
what I wanted to cover today.
And then next time, we are going
to talk about-- let me see,
do I have a--
we're going to talk
about the cortical areas
involved in saccadic eye
movements control,
which we will then
highlight the fact that this
incessant activity of us moving
the eyes is incredibly
elaborate and complicated.
There are millions of
neurons involved in doing it.
And yet, it's such
an incredible system
that it's something we
never even think about.
Luckily, it's a kind of system--
partly because of the fact
that there's no wait
involved in the muscles,
and that the fibers run
the entire length of each
of the extraocular muscles-- it
is a system that one has been
fortunate enough to
understand reasonably
well in how it
works in the brain.
So that, in essence, is what
I wanted to cover today.
If any of you have
any questions,
anything that-- I know this
is kind of complicated,
but I hope that
you will understand
this reasonably well.
And if it's not
clear to you, I will
be very happy to answer any
questions that you might have.
Well, I was
reasonably clear then.
So next time-- here's my
to-do-- the cortex, heavily.
I will also show you some
interesting movies about that.
And I think you're
going to find that it's
a really fascinating story
of how the cortex has evolved
to generate more and more
areas that are involved
in an incredible
number of functions
in the generation of eye
movements, as well, of course,
as in processing
visual information.
OK.
Well, thank you very much.